[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ses points de vue on est
en direct comme chaque soir pour
débattre de deux sujets chauds de
l'actualité avec deux experts aussi
affûté que pertinent bonsoir christophe
de voogd bonsoir vous êtes historien
professeur à sciences po vous présidez
le conseil scientifique de la fondapol
fondation de sensibilité libérale bien
connu vous avez d'ailleurs contribué à
l'un des derniers ouvrages de la
fondapol et je le retrouve tout de suite
et moc démocratie sous tension merci
heureusement nos internautes le voit
donc ils peuvent pallier mes nombreuses
insuffisances démocratie tension qui est
paru en 2010 9,7 une grande enquête
d'opinion sur l'état de la démocratie au
milieu du 21e siècle au début plutôt du
21e siècle et mathieu st-pierre est là
avec lou bonsoir vous êtes consultant
merci beaucoup très bonne année à vous
aussi tous mes voeux vous êtes
consultant expert associé à la fondation
jean jaurès et vous avez été les
collaborateurs de la ministre du travail
socialiste myriam el khomri nous allons
commencer par parler si vous le voulez
bien de la fameuse stratégie vaccinale
vous savez celle qui nouveau la risée du
monde entier
alors il y avait un certain nombre de
gens qui s'occupaient de ce dossier bien
sûr les ministres concernés mais aussi
santé publique france la haute autorité
de santé le conseil d'orientation de la
stratégie vaccinale
le comité scientifique le comité des 35
citoyens tirés au sort pour surveiller
tout ça mais apparemment ce n'était pas
assez
et donc le gouvernement s'est adjoint
les services d'un cabinet prestigieux de
conseil en stratégie qui s'appelle
mckinsey cabinet d'origine américaine
qui n'est pas réputé pour la modicité de
ses honoraires et
l'objectif est de se faire aider pour le
déploiement de cette stratégie vaccinale
est ce une bonne idée on va en parler
mais je vous propose d'écouter d'abord
le l'opinion de thierry mariani député
du rassemblement national qui rappelle à
juste titre qu'en fait c'est pas la
première fois que le secteur public et
le gouvernement se fait ainsi conseillé
j'avais un resserrement raison ça s'est
déjà fait ça se fera encore mais là pour
quoi c'est choquant parce qu'en réalité
là on a une véritable administration qui
existent je veux dire on n'est pas on
n'est pas en situation de pénurie a
aujourd'hui faire appel à un cabinet
extérieur pour organiser tout ça d'abord
c'est un aveu d'échec
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
loeb qui conseille le gouvernement n'est
pas totalement un inconnu puisqu'il
s'agit de maele de canon ceux qui
suivent de près l'actualité politique se
souviennent peut-être que ce jeune
juppéiste élu local en bretagne avait
été candidat malheureux à la tête des
républicains
alors match car je le disais vous avez
collaboré à des cabinets ministériels
ça vous a surpris apparemment ce n'est
pas une première l'état fait souvent
appel à des cabinets extérieurs
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
fonctionnaires dans ce pays donc on peut
comprendre que quand il ya besoin
d'appuis alors ça ne me paraît pas
nécessairement de mauvaises méthodes
la plupart des grandes entreprises elles
mêmes qui sont en général plutôt bien
staff et des grands groupes les
multinationales elles mêmes ont
régulièrement recours à des cabinets
extérieurs pour les aider dans leur
conduite du changement dans leur
rationalisation dans leur réorganisation
c'est assez banal j'ai moi même
accompagné pendant quelques mois le bcg
le bcg a parmi ses clients beaucoup
d'acteurs privés qui ne se porte pas
trop mal et quand je crois pas que ce
soit la laisser penser ce ne sont pas
des spécialistes en vaccins c'est le
boston consulting group qui est l'autre
grand cabinet de stratégie bcg avec
maclean's absolument absolument
donc je crois pas que ce soit une
mauvaise méthode il y as derrière cela
malgré tout l'idée que qui correspond à
une tarte à la crème qu'on entretient
depuis très longtemps mais qui là à
quelques réalités
le fait que le public serait synonyme
comme toujours en fait d'inertie
d'improductivité d'inefficacité et
aurait toujours besoin du privé qui lui
serait au contraire synonyme de
performance et d'efficience toujours
besoin du privé pour bien agir non alors
encore une fois si on prend un tout
petit peu de recul quand même puisque
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
on tombe sur nos autorités admis
istrati faisait politique à bras
raccourcis à peu près tous tous les
matins j'ai été indulgent sur les
masques j'ai été indulgent sur les
masques parce qu'encore une fois on a
certes manqué de masques mais tout le
monde a manqué de masques nous on aurait
pu en banque et moins que les autres
puisqu'il se trouve que pendant
plusieurs années on avait constitué des
stocks considérables qu'on avait
malheureusement ensuite décaissé donc on
n'a pas une au mas moi et j'ai été
indulgent au moment des masques étaient
ensuite indulgent au moment du
confinement
parce qu'encore une fois on est face à
des problématiques qui sont tellement
complexes
on ne peut être indulgent les tests les
lacs sa part dont on les a là en
revanche effectivement c'est plus
étonnant puisque on se préparait à cette
stratégie vaccinale et je dirais même
qu'on n'était pas pris de court
contrairement au printemps au mois de
mars où on a vu arriver une vague un
virus que personne n'attendait que
personne n'avait vu venir
là pour le coup la stratégie vaccinale
on savait qu'on aurait à la déployer en
début d'année on l'avait même présenté
au parlement alors très rapidement mais
elle avait été présentée au parlement il
ya déjà deux mois donc on savait à quoi
s'attendre et donc je vous avoue que je
ne sais pas dans quelle mesure et
bienveillant je ne fais pas du mal à
jeter un au gouvernement alors le
soutenir ou ou l'accabler n'est pas mon
n'est pas mon sujet en fait j'ai du mal
à m'expliquer ce qui s'est passé ça je
vous avoue que j'ai du mal à me
l'expliquer en revanche je ne sais pas
si la problématique essentielle c'est
l'inertie administrative lille où le
manque d'anticipation de la part de nos
gouvernants que cette stratégie
vaccinale la démarrant très lentement
créerait dans l'opinion un trouble
profond
dès lors que tous nos voisins eux mêmes
il irait beaucoup plus vite à la
vendange c'est ça qui pose pas la ligne
oran via un makine je ne sais pas si
pour autant nous sommes la risée en fête
mondiale
je ne sais pas ce que ce que ce que les
autres pays qui eux mêmes sont débordés
ce 10 de ce que fait la france
il est vrai que nous avions une strate
d'une stratégie vaccinale particulière
qui aurait dû mobiliser en réalité un
très grand nombre
un très grand nombre d'acteurs publics
et au premier rang desquels les
collectivités publiques
donc je ne sais pas si c'était au privé
qu'il fallait avoir recours on aurait pu
commencer par mettre les régions et les
maires les collectivités locales dans la
boucle
à dr et ont été beaucoup plus et nos
internautes sont assez sévères avons
nous besoin d'un cabinet de conseil
privé pour assurer la vaccination contre
le coc u19 c'est non à 75%
c'est pas toujours mal oui mais ludovic
sur youtube nous dit c'est une affaire
de santé publique et non privé pourquoi
alors utiliser des cabinets de conseil
privé peut-être qu'un cabinet privé
serait plus à même considère au
contraire roland de donner certains
conseils que la bureaucratie française
qu'en pensez vous et puis exane ya aussi
sur twitter qui dit mais tous les pays
ont commencé la vaccination
ah non tous les pays qui ont commencé la
vaccination n'ont pas eu besoin de
cabinet de conseil alors pourquoi nous
christophe devaux qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
je me dis vous devez être partagé entre
votre sensibilité libérale qui vous fait
dire tant mieux si l'état fait appel au
privé et en même temps une forme de
sévérité par rapport à l'administration
non non je me réjouis jamais d'un échec
ce serait du chardon freud lance dans un
avion je suis juste sur le fait de faire
appel à un cabinet de conseil comme
maclean's est et bien sûr je parle dans
le même sens un petit peu d'abord que
mathieu parce que j'ai aussi une experte
de cabinets ministériels et c'est pas ce
ne sont pas des procédures totalement
absurde d'ailleurs les entreprises
endettées et feront appel parce que
qu'est-ce qu'on a besoin d'un regard
extérieur c'est ça l'idée c'est à dire
que les gens qui sont dans la place par
définition sont pris dans les filets de
l'action quotidienne et ne voit même
plus qu ils font donc on a besoin d'un
regard extérieur c'est le principe du
lot dit
en fait cela dit c'est quand même un
très gros problème
en effet soit c'est une question de
stratégie et cette stratégie elle est
déterminée par le président de la
république soit c'est une question de
fonctionnement et là ça quand même ça
pose la question de notre administration
et pour avoir justement été un grand
cabinet je sais que cette administration
est très inégale en fait bien il ya des
directions qui fonctionne très bien des
ministères qui fonctionne très bien
regarder bercy en ce moment mais on y
met aussi les meilleurs fonctionnaires
et puis oui parce que il ya deux jours
sur ce plateau
nicolas baverez a dit les choses de
façon encore plus peut-être dur ou
explicite que vous en disant faut bien
reconnaître que ce sont pas les
meilleurs énarque qui vont au ministère
de la seconde et je referme cette
parenthèse analystes et puis il ya des
médias il y avait une sorte de
d'engourdissement
son public qui moi j'ai constaté cours
de ma carrière déjà longue et qui est
frappante et qui me rappelle un conseil
allez voir que je ne peux être un peu la
dent dure mais ce qui vient deux de mes
vieux amis conseiller d'alain poher nous
rajeunit pas guillaume roquette jeu
quand même qu'il a fait un peu de
monnerville vous voyez et qui me disait
quand je suis rentré dans
l'administration justement qui me disait
le principe de l'administration il avait
un merveilleux accent bourguignon c'est
ne rien faire tout fait faire de revenir
laisser faire et 7 ce triptyque
magnifique et même dépassés par les
événements parce qu'on ne sait même plus
faire faire et ça c'est un des gros
problèmes que j'ai vu aussi à se
développer dans l'administration de j'ai
envoyé un mail j'ai envoyé une note donc
j'ai fait non il ya toujours le problème
du dernier kilomètre
comme disent les logisticiens qui n'est
pas réglée c'est à dire que vous avez
une production qui finit par être à vide
où vous écrivez justement quand vous
multipliez les niveaux hiérarchiques
les organismes parce que là c'est vous
qui avait été indulgents guillaume
enquête
quand vous avez cité des acteurs
impliqués mais voilà mais vous êtes très
loin du compte
vous êtes très loin du compte et ça vous
ça crée automatiquement un brouillard
c'est à dire qu'on ne sait plus qui fait
quoi au sein de l'administration même et
on se concentre à ce moment là de dire
ah bah j'ai bien consulter machin est ce
que j'ai bien envoyée à la hiérarchie
d'accord mais on ne s'occupe plus du
dernier kilomètre
et ça c'est un phénomène qui est pas due
à la mauvaise qualité des fonctionnaires
forcément un qui est aussi dit tout
simplement à une logique de système donc
faire appel au privé n'est pas en soi
scandaleux mais en effet moi je
maintiens et quand même un très mauvais
signe de fonctionnement de notre
administration et j'ajouterais quelque
chose lorsque le ministre de la santé
qui n'a pas été relevé je crois même pas
par le figaro guillaume enquête lorsque
biais de la santé dit hier j'ai demandé
au préfet d'identifier des endroits où
l'on pourrait désigner personne ne
bronche
nous sommes le 5 nous étions hier le 5
janvier autrement dit ces stratégies
vaccinales n'avait pas prévu de lieu
d'identifier identification je parle
d'identification s'est passé comme une
lettre à la poste
il est évident que la première chose à
faire c'est se dire si on vaccine où on
vaccine 5 janvier
ouais je peux être que plus de plus rien
ne nous surprend dans la gestion de
cette campagne vaccinale est que si on
doit tous relevé pas mal et pas mal cela
surtout que on sait que les
collectivités locales ont été très
nombreuses à faire remonter aux préfets
des propositions de lieux pour vacciner
etc
vous disiez à juste titre mathieu
soutient que les grandes entreprises
privées aussi faisait appel à ce genre
de cabinet de conseil pour en avant
l'expérience je me demande si ya pas une
différence entre ces grandes entreprises
et l'administration c'est que dans une
grande entreprise fait venir le cabinet
est comme ça coûte cher
vous êtes attentif et ensuite vous
modifier l'organisation pour pour
l'adapter en fonction ce qui a été
préconisé
alors que dans l'administration il ya
les statuts les carrières les
organigrammes et rien ne bouge jamais
non là pour le coup je pense que vous
raisonner à partir d'un lieu commun le
secteur public s'est énormément
énormément réformer au cours des 20 ou
25 dernières années je ne dis pas qu'il
est devenue efficace ou efficient en
toute chose mais je pense que il y a peu
de corps sociaux qui ont autant évolué
que la fonction publique depuis une
vingtaine d'années donc encore une fois
un jeune dis pas que c'est parfait mais
la rgpp et et tout ce qui s'en est suivi
a quand même créé de de vrai mouvement
dans la fonction publique non savoir
deux fois vous rendez hommage à sarkozy
notation mais parce qu on rappelle que
la revue générale des politiques
publiques
c'est pour ça que vous faisiez les
masques absolument ça devient grave
en revanche pour ne pas effectivement
être indulgent avec nos gouvernants et
et faire une lecture politique du sujet
il y avait quand même dans le maquereau
nisme au départ du maquereau nice une
promesse d'efficacité
une promesse de professionnalisme le
gouvernement des meilleurs le
dépassement du gauche droite au profit
encore une fois efficace de l'efficacité
là on a rarement en fait vu
collectivement autant d'inefficacité et
encore une fois autant sur les
précédentes étapes de la crise sanitaire
je ne suis pas sûr que la france ait
fait pire que ses voisins au contraire
il ya eu un certain nombre d'études
global bond qui ont montré clairement
c'était plutôt dans un peloton normal en
revanche là il est vrai que sur cette
stratégie vaccinale
c'est très surprenant alors encore une
fois le gouvernement des meilleurs et la
technocratie et la verticalité du
pouvoir et la centralisation de la
décision on peut voir ce que ça ce que
ce que ça donne
jane et ça pour le coup c'est purement
mac revient c'est une stratégie définie
par le président de la république et un
fonctionnement ensuite de la sphère
publique qui est déterminé par le chef
et ça ça peut politiquement quand même
coûté très cher parce que même s'il ya
parfois beaucoup d'excès dans le
jugement de l'opinion l'opinion quand
même si on se résume ses 68 millions de
personnes ultra compétente qui seraient
gouvernées par 200 types totalement
incompétent quand on entend quand même
le discours commun c'est de plus en plus
cela donc sans doute que la réalité est
un peu différente
il n'empêche que il y a une vraie crise
de confiance cette crise de confiance
repose en particulier sur une trêve une
crise de l'efficacité de l'action
publique et là on est au coeur du
problème et macro lui-même dans son
interview à brut il y a quelques
semaines disait je ne sais pas pour 2022
je ne sais même pas si je serai en
situation de me représenter
s'il en fait quelques unes comme ça il
fait peu il fait peu de doute que il
sera en hollande isation en fin de
quinquennat et peut-être mis dans une
situation où il ne sera pas en capacité
de se représenter avait tout à fait
raison d'ailleurs vous êtes un des aussi
un des rares à avoir relevé ce passage à
mon avis a peut-être le plus important
de toute l'interview de brut et qui me
paraît tout à fait lucide heures plus
est sur la carte des administrations à
la jasse rappeur des accords parce que
moi je les ai vus évoluer cette
administration qu'est ce qu'elle a fait
et notamment parfois au nom de la
simplification de l'administration
qu'est ce qu'on a vu ce sont des couches
successives qui se sont créé notre grand
problème tout le monde le sait il est
dans tous les secteurs n'ont pas à
problèmes budgétaires ça nous sommes
tous les chiffres mais un problème de
sur administration par rapport encore
une fois ceux qui font faire ce qu'ils
interdisent de faire par rapport à ce
qu'ils font
on le voit dans l'éducation nationale je
suis placé pour le savoir on le voit
évidemment dans la santé alors que
l'hôpital est aussi bien doté que beat à
la demande vous avez 35 %
d'administratifs en plus
donc vous avez un problème et je les ai
vus moi je vous dis je les ai vus je le
vois systématiquement c'est-à-dire
concret souvent au nom de l'efficacité
une couche supplémentaire
d'administration qui au lieu d'accentuer
la et d'efficacité va retarder hong ap
le procès se déroule en public il a vu
récemment mois sur un dossier où j'ai vu
le dossier bloqué par un étage qui
venait d'être inventé et pendant ce
temps on n'a plus personne ne fait rien
il est assez logique parce que l'état
nouvellement inventé doit prouver fait
la preuve de son utilité et sa capacité
de nuisance en est une preuve comme une
autre
vous avez mauvais esprit mais la maison
en tout cas et sept étages il a été fait
je peux vous le dire j'ai vu les
motivations de du décret pour des
raisons de simplification
en fait il a introduit une étape de plus
dans le processus administratif et s'il
ne résout réagit pas au moment où il est
sollicité tout le processus est bloqué
et je vous garantis je serais prêt à
parier que dans le cas de la santé c'est
exactement ce qu'ils sont alors on tombe
on dope sur l'inertie pendant daube sur
les marchés nombreux ont donc bien
souvent sur l'inertie de la fonction
publique et aussi sur sa sueur ça sur
son extrême prudence voire même sa
frilosité face à des décisions ou qui
serait uniquement motivés pour des
fonctionnaires par le fait de sortir son
parapluie de se protéger sans doute et
en même temps on voit bien que le
ministre de la santé dont on parlait à
l'instant lui-même a fait l'objet de
perquisitions en pleine crise pandémique
parce que l'opinion elle même de plus en
plus traîne ses gouvernants devant la
justice donc je je devrais madar zéro en
la matière puisque si l'opinion voulait
aussi des hauts fonctionnaires parfois
plus courageux ou plus téméraires il
faudrait qu'elles font l'opinion pouvait
se comporter
il faudrait empêcher la justice mais
c'est un autre débat d'interférer à ce
point dans la gestion des affaires en
cours je rappelle qu'un certain nombre
de buts de non seulement de ministres et
hauts fonctionnaires absolument faire
l'objet d'enquêtés une manière pour mise
en danger de la vie d'autrui et homicide
involontaire absolument docsis malraux
n'essayez pas de protéger un peu oui
mais attention il ya deux il ya une
chose là attention je pense que si on
met en cause la sa [ __ ] et pénales je
suis pas le seul à le dire c'est parce
que les autres feront de responsabilité
ne fonctionne plus au sein de la
fonction publique que je connais bien
l'avouer les professionnels c'est à dire
que que vous agissiez bien pas bien
moins bien et c'est ça ne changera rien
à votre carrière
et deuxièmement la stabilité politique 1
le fameux j'assume qui ne veut
strictement rien dire puisque assumer ça
veut dire assumer politiquement donc
démissionner éventuellement où aller
devant le parlement et bien appartement
vous n'avez plus ni responsabilité
professionnelle ni responsabilité
politique
eh bien vous avez automatiquement un
court-circuit qui se fait pas la
responsabilité pénale et je pense qu'on
devrait revoir ses questions de
responsabilité qui à mon avis ont eu
l'effet pervers mais qui s'explique
encore une fois par un refus ce de
l'ordre normal des choses c'est une
explication passionnante que tu avais
jamais entendu
encore merci beaucoup et on laisse le
dernier mot à nos internautes c'est
notamment à babineau bien sûr le premier
d'entre eux il dit qu'il ne comprend pas
le rôle de monsieur fisher dans la
campagne de vaccination ah oui c'est
vrai qu'il avait oublié celui-là il ya
aussi un monsieur vaccin qui est de la
logistique du tout voilà équipe je sais
c'est que c'est pas sur la sphère et qu'
il faut quand même très vigilant parce
que ce vaccin on sait pas très bien s'il
n'y a pas des conséquences secondaires
donc avec des alliés comme ça on n'a
plus besoin d'ennemis et dan avec un peu
de sarcasme nous demande si en dehors de
la question du besoin ou non de cabinets
privés
on n'aurait pas surtout besoin d'un
autre gouvernement va coûter c'est un
point de vue et je vous le laisse je le
laisse pardon à votre appréciation
autres sujets que nous souhaitions
traiter cet après-midi ce sondage sans
doute inquiétant il a été réalisé par
l'ifop pour la fondation jean jaurès
dont vous êtes l'un des experts cher
mathieu et pour notre confrère charlie
hebdo
on a interrogé des professeurs sur ce
qu'on appelle la laïcité c'est à dire
sur la capacité à a parlé de tout
notamment dans un contexte où certains
élèves de confession musulmane peuvent
avoir un regard très critique sur ce qui
est fait voici une question dans votre
école ou établissements scolaires des
enseignements font-ils l'objet de
contestations et certains élèves ont-ils
tenté de s'y soustraire
c'est oui à 53% c'est quand même un
chiffre très élevé ça veut dire que ce
sont pas des phénomènes minoritaire
c'est plus d'un professeur sur deux avec
une augmentation très sensible + 7
points depuis 2018 et sa mort est une
conséquence de ce constat le près de la
moitié des professeurs 49% pour être
tout à fait précis indiquent que pour
éviter des incidents possible il leur
est déjà arrivé de s'auto censurer ce
sujet préoccupe jusqu'au sommet de
l'état
écoutez la mention que faisait
manuellement macron pardon dans ses
voeux le 31 décembre dernier
mention d'un professeur de marseille
mehdi et professeur de sciences
économiques et sociales dans les
quartiers nord de marseille
comme des milliers d'enseignants il a eu
quelques jours après l'assassinât de
samuel patty a organisé un cours sur la
laïcité
pour cela il a pris le temps de se
former auprès d'autres professeurs et
inspecteurs d'académie et avec courage
il est alors revenu auprès de ses élèves
sur nos valeurs
leur histoire assumant cette haute
mission de notre école de nos
enseignants faire des républicains voilà
ça c'est la belle histoire qu'on raconte
aux français pour la saint sylvestre la
réalité peut-être un tout petit peu plus
complexe que ça peut-être avez-vous
entendu parler de cette grève des
enseignants d'un collège lyonnais qui
s'appelle l'eba tiers l'histoire est
toute simple elle semble tristement
banale c'est celle d'un professeur
d'histoire géo qui après l'assassinât de
samuel patty hewes explique à ses élèves
ce qu'est la laïcité il leur explique
que la démarche de l'état n'est pas
islamophobe mais il ya deux élèves qui
ça ne plaît pas de jeune d'une famille
récemment arrivés en france
leur père agressent verbalement très
fortement ce prof
le prof porte plainte et que croyez-vous
qu'il advint eba la plainte a été
classée sans suite par la justice
le professeur à changer d'établissement
et les deux élèves sont toujours dans
l'école alors que les profs avaient
demandé l'éducation nationale qui soit
changer de collège et bien ça ne s'est
pas fait
christophe de voc ont titre de façon
peut-être un peu sombre un combat perdu
sur ces questions on a des études delà
de la fondapol que vous avez mentionné
tout à l'heure sur notamment on a le fan
étude sur l'antisémitisme dans les
milieux musulmans et en france en
général on a fait des études sur dans la
question de la démocratie sur la place
de l'islam est sûre c'est tout c'est que
tous ces enjeux majeurs je vais pas vous
faire durant même temps en tout cas ça
pose déjà pour faire le plein liaison et
le sujet précédent ça pose le problème
de l'administration de la réaction
administrative de sa réactivité et dans
la sphère de sa mère pattie je crois
qu'il faut pas trop chercher à les
chercher trop loin puisque vous savez
qu'il n'était pas forcément en odeur de
sainteté lui-même dans l'administration
de l'éducation nationale pas de vagues
tel est souvent l'un est ce à dire
c'était un hashtag a parmi les
professeurs ont concours nam-il
témoignage en dehors de ce sondage de
l'autocensure des enseignants qui je le
crains de gagner très rapidement le
supérieur il faut voir les choses telles
qu'elles sont et c'est le professeur
d'université qui parle je ne vais pas
encore pratiqué cette autocensure mais
je peux vous dire que avec la canne seul
catcheur convoi arrivait voyez puis les
micros agression on peut craindre et
c'est d'ailleurs à déjà avérée dans
certain nombre d'établissements à
l'université on peut craindre que cette
censure ne cette autocensure que cette
censure tout court 1 puisque là il
s'agit d'une autocensure falla d'une
vraie censure puisque le père est
intervenu non non je crois que on a on a
donc des raisons de s'inquiéter on a
aussi des raisons d'espérer parce que
malgré tout une majorité très nette
majorité de français
on a eu d un sondage récent sur ces
questions est favorable à un
renforcement de la laïcité et pas d'une
laïcité jeudi rêve ouverte mais d'une
laïcité stricte un tir de défense de
l'état par rapport à tout empiètement du
religieux car ce cas le sens profond et
historique de la laïcité
donc on aurait on voit quand même un
mouvement de fond qui s'est évidemment
accentué avec les attentats de l'opinion
publique dans ce sens et on a quand même
majorité nette de musulmans qui est
favorable on va dire à l'ordre
républicain en général le vrai problème
et ils se posent sur la jeunesse
musulmane et là c'est un enjeu
d'ailleurs les études de jean jaurès
dans le même sens et ça c'est un enjeu
l'orage j'aimerais bien qu'on en finisse
avec c'est pas à l'école de régler ce
problème vous le voyez bien elle en est
incapable
il faut que la ce soit c'est un problème
global de la société française c'est un
problème médiatique
c'est un problème médiatique c'est un
problème culturel au sens large femme
géniale familiales et d'autres d'eau
d'air d'autres sondages sont
intéressants parce qu'il ya pas que la
jeunesse musulmane la genèse en général
et sur ces questions - allante que le
reste de la population
et là je je je connecte sac ce que je
vous disais sur des étudiants qui est le
relativisme culturel c'est-à-dire cette
idée que j'ai mes convictions talent
etienne t'as pas le droit de parler des
miennes on n'a pas le chacun chez soi ce
qui rend tout simplement impossible je
ne peux même pas le mot projet
républicain mais ce qui rend tout
simplement impossible le moindre
dialogue social donc cette cette
situation est tendue et je pense qu'il
faudra agir très vite et surtout encore
une fois arrêté de se déposer sur
l'école car justement le problème y est
déjà
je vous livre ses commentaires
d'internautes celui de marie qui sur
figaro.fr jusqu'à preuve du contraire
ces enfants ont des parents
donc le problème est aussi chez les
adultes parents écrit-il c'était bien le
sait bien le père de ses enfants qui a
agressé verbalement l'enseignant dans le
cas de ce collège lyonnais et puis cette
réaction de clément sur youtube qui lui
on considère que contrairement à
d'autres sujets abordés à l'école
l'idée de la laïcité forcément influencé
par le ressenti et l'opinion de
l'enseignante c'est un peu ce
relativisme dans vous parliez alors at
elle vraiment sa place à l'école
s'interroge-t-il
sur twitter où on vous pose la question
devons nous continuer d'enseigner la
laïcité à l'école
la réponse est oui à 88% et tous les
sondages récents macbook air quand vous
avez pris connaissance de ce sondage est
ce que papa celui de sur twitter qui
n'est pas un sondage d'ailleurs mais une
prise de température entre guillemets de
nos internautes mais le sondage
réalisé pour charlie hebdo et votre
institut est ce que ça vous a inquiété
pas du tout alors pas du tout je suis à
peu près d'accord avec jeu d'accord avec
à peu près tout ce qu'a dit christophe
et jeu mais je suis un ardent partisan
du relativisme pas du tout parce que si
on regarde dans le détail il ya
effectivement un certain nombre de
données qui sont un peu inquiétantes et
en particulier le fait qu' il y a
souvent des écarts dans la perception de
la jeunesse et des autres et il ya un
certain nombre de signaux qui peuvent
être considéré comme inquiétant
dès lors qu'on se concentre qu'on se
focalise sur le public jeune je fais le
lien d'ailleurs avec une une grosse
série d' enquête que la fondation jean
jaurès a déjà publié est qu'il ya eu pas
mal d'échos médiatiques sur le
complotisme le complotisme prospère
beaucoup dans la société française
aujourd'hui et en particulier très
spécifiquement chez les jeunes donc ça
c'est tout à fait inquiétant il suffit
pas d'envoyer des jeunes à l'école pour
que face à des théories complotistes
absolument farfelue il se montre en
capacité de faire preuve d'esprit
critique
donc c'est tout à fait inquiétant mais
sur cette enquête particulière je suis
pas d'accord avec la présentation vous
en faites la tonalité que vous lui
donnez y compris le titre
il ya effectivement la moitié dans
l'interrogation
ouais il ya la moitié des enseignants
qui sont confrontés à cette réalité là
que personne ne découvre mais quand on
regarde dans le détail il y à 7 % des
enseignants qui se disent confrontés à
cette réalité là de façon régulière
voilà 7 % seulement des enseignants qui
sont confrontées de de façon régulière
et 17% qui sont confrontés de temps en
temps
donc 17 +7 ça fait vingt-quatre un car
on peut dire c'est beaucoup mais les
trois quarts des enseignants donc tout
de même ils sont pas du tout confrontée
de façon régulière au maire d'angers
quand même on n'a pas inventé ce
c'est dans cette question dans votre
école ou établissements les y at-il eu
des contestations c'est pas oui à 27%
c'est oui à 53%
bien sûr non mais je regarde une fois je
cherche pas à minimiser
j'espère quand même non non pas du tout
non pas du tout vraiment pas il ya des
choses qui sont parfois très inquiétante
je ne trouve pas que ce sondage ne
disent que des choses inquiétantes
certaines et certains éléments posent
question bien sûr mais pas tous y
compris donc sur les faits de
contestation quels sont ils
participation à un cours de sport menus
à la cantine et c'est même là c'est
assez subtil
encore une fois les interdits
alimentaires à la cantine les interdits
alimentaires à la cantine aujourd'hui
pardon encore une fois mais le le
véganisme est à la mode
on est végétarien et on est végétarien
pour des raisons philosophiques
philosophico politique qui se défendre
et donc on voudrait qu'il y ait
davantage de menus végétariens à la
cantine personne ne lui en le loup et et
tout le monde même se pose la question
et se pose la question de façon positive
et même favorables
quant à faire évoluer les menus
scolaires en tenant compte de cette
préoccupation doute parce qu'à moins de
séparatisme vegan que de séparatisme en
quoi très sincèrement encore à aborder
cette question pose t elle problème et
fragilise tel le socle républicain
j'ai pendant toute ma scolarité manger
du poisson un vendredi callac jour ça et
encore une fois dans une école publique
je ne suis moi même pas catholique n'ait
jamais été heurté par le fait de manger
du poisson pané le vendredi je n'aimais
pas le poisson pané
mais encore une fois je ne me sentais
pas atteint encore une fois dans dans ma
laïcité donc je pense qu'il faut
regarder les choses est sûre même la
notion d' auto-censure elle est très
intéressante
alors effectivement la moitié des
enseignants disent qu'ils sont
fréquemment sujets à l'autocensure je je
je prends cet exemple avec des pincettes
parce qu'il est sensible mais je
réfléchissais y compris à semelle pâtit
qu'on se mêle pop hâtif et son cours
son cours qui malheureusement est
dramatiquement lui coûtera très cher
quand il fait son cours lui même fait
preuve d'une forme d'autocensure
car il ne balance pas la caricature à à
ses élèves comme ça il prévient ses
élèves qui va leur présenter une
caricature et que l'événement soit celle
de la lettre ils pourraient être choqués
de ne pas y rester
et encore une fois personne n'a pointé
le fait que l'attitude de samuel pâtit
était en soi choquant
il a pris des précautions ce qu'on
appelle
on peut appeler ce qu'on n'aurait pas
dit mais un sonore que vous auriez dit
dans ses premiers à dire il a vraiment
vous violez la conscience de ses élèves
maintenant je dis juste que ce qu'on
peut appeler de l'autocensure c'est
parfois tout simplement en fait une
prise de précautions qui n'est pas
absurde
encore une fois ne pas heurter je ne
défends rien en la matière juste ne pas
heurter la sensibilité de la personne à
laquelle on s'adresse
voire même au contraire vouloir ne pas
heurter sa sensibilité pour par ailleurs
lui tenir un discours qui lui inculque
de l'esprit critique et des valeurs
républicaines ne me paraît pas de
mauvaises méthodes qui soit vous êtes
vous rassuré par cette analyse de
l'oeuvre comme je disais je ne suis pas
catastrophé
je dis qu'il est temps d'agir et c'est
ce qui me fait très peur encore une fois
ses 7,7 des fausses généralisée à
commencer par la classe politique en
général
il faut que l'école vous avez remarqué
que sur tous les sujets en france où il
ya un problème
à commencer par les excès de vitesse
conergy et l'écologie la consommation
excessive de pain d épices et bien on va
demander à l'école du coup on apprend
plus de matches on doit bien on a plus
d'accord du français on n'a plus l'homme
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire soit 360
disciplines différentes d'accord pour
lesquels les professeurs ne sont pas
formés et qui visuellement disperse le
temps scolaire donc l'école comme l'état
et tout se tient devrait peut-être se
recentrer sur ses fondamentaux sur la
laïcité
à condition qu'on arrive à se mettre
d'accord sur ce que ça veut dire parce
que je peux vous dire que je suis les
historiens il ya une grande biais de
grands débats
en tout cas sur un socle à discuter il y
avait quand même un socle un peu en
discuter et attention quand même aux
comparaisons que je trouve toujours un
peu un peu rapide qui sont à la limite
du sophisme quand vous mangez du poisson
c'était pas du tout vous n'avez pas du
tout réagit comme un musulman à qui en
ferait manger du porc oui ce que je veux
dire le gros lot dit bru donc c'est
justement ce que vous pointez marque la
totale différence entre le fait que vous
laïques etc
vous n'étiez pas gêné par le fait qu'une
vieille prescriptions dont tout le monde
avait oublié mais gêné mais persona mais
l'année par cette prescription à
l'événement mais pour autant le principe
est bien le même encore une fois il
s'agissait d'un interdits alimentaires
pour raison d'un interdit alimentaire
pour d'origine religieuse et vous ne
riez riez pas mais personne de son
amoureux
mais pourquoi se marient me voir et on
l'émouvoir il maintenant je vais faire
maintenant ça fait un drame et sa
béquille gens là qui s'en émeut
mais pourquoi pourquoi il s'en émeut la
question c'est pourquoi cela fait-il un
drame le célèbre dégration l'intérêt de
leur pays l'intégration dans nos pays ne
fonctionnent pas aussi mal qu'on le dit
en permanence et il ya en particulier
deux administrations qui intègre plutôt
bien en particulier l'armée l'armée et
la police mais en particulier l'armée
l'armée compte en son sein une vraie
diversité c'est pour ça qu'il n'aurait
jamais fallu supprimer le service
militaire certes mais pardonnez moi cher
christophe dans l'armée on sert tous les
jours des menus halal ou des menus
cacher et personne n'en parle mais je
suis très bien j'y suis favorable
je pointais simplement votre
raisonnement votre raisonnement ne
connais pas puisque vous démontriez le
contraire de ce que vous dites merci
beaucoup monsieur pour ce débat
passionnant on a failli terminer sur un
socle indiscuté mais non finalement la
production quasiment à à la merci à vous
tous de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous
demain même heure même endroit pour une
nouvelle édition du point de vue
[Musique]